today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
so i mentioned earlier this week that
there's something uh palpable
in the air that feels different since
joe biden won the presidential election
even though joe biden is not yet the
president
just something feels like we're starting
to have a shot
at no longer being a laughingstock
globally and
getting back on a better path and it's
sort of a vague thing
but there's something not vague that is
very quickly changing which is that the
world is starting to ignore donald trump
there's still months until joe biden is
actually inaugurated as president of the
united states and even though
donald trump has refused to concede the
election and is talking about
legal fights and lawsuits and he really
won and all of this stuff
um the world is already dealing with joe
biden
as the adult in the room and is starting
to just ignore donald trump and it is
extremely triggering for donald trump
the biden transition team
is moving along biden launched his own
coronavirus task force
they've already met world leaders are
calling joe biden and talking to him
about the future
boris johnson said he spoke to joe biden
and it was
refreshing but on the other side of the
equation
you were seeing donald trump just being
ignored
earlier in the week fox news cut away
from his press secretary
kaylee mckennany that was i think monday
for wildly repeating baseless voter
fraud allegations they're just tired of
it
the leaders of major allies like germany
and the united kingdom and israel have
congratulated and welcomed
joe biden joe biden has announced key
appointments and they're being dealt
with
by the serious media as appointments by
a president-elect not
some guy who hasn't really won this uh
applies to the coronavirus task force
joe biden's selection yesterday the day
before yesterday of ronald mclean as uh
chief of staff
so this is not the world that trump
wants
to be real but it is real and
media outlets are covering it world
leaders are now dealing with biden many
trump staffers are privately saying
the entire contesting the election thing
is pointless
courts have so far found all of donald
trump's various legal challenges to be
completely
spurious and without merit and social
media platforms are also more
aggressively flagging donald trump's
completely unhinged posts as
election-related
misinformation look at newspapers around
the world after reporting the election
results
newspapers have moved on from trump
newspapers around the world are
discussing joe biden's possible cabinet
joe biden's possible foreign policy how
would a joe biden presidency
affect our relationship meaning these
other countries relationships with the
united states
and the contrast is just stunning trump
is tweeting that he won stuff
and suing people while joe biden
announces
policy advisers staffers and more
trump tweets bogus voter fraud
conspiracy theories
meanwhile biden's holding a coronavirus
task force meeting so
let's keep the focus on moving forward
let's not indulge the possibility
that there will be any other outcome but
at the same time let's remember that
there are
what 71 72 million people that voted for
donald trump
many of them like to moonlight as
militia members many could spill out
into the streets if this continues and
what we have to hope for
as trump fires people and has who knows
what up his sleeve if anything
we have to hope that our institutions
are more solid
than uh a few people that trump is
moving around during the transition
and once we get past it we get past it
and it's over
unless trump runs in 2024 but we're not
even dealing with that right now so
again
trump threatening to leave the country
if he loses
saying it's rigged filing lawsuits
firing dissidents or even people not
completely on board with what he says
these are all actions that around the
world we've seen done by some pretty bad
people over the last hundred plus years
but in the end trump is going to go now
one other thing
donald trump has not been taken totally
seriously
by the media and leaders of many
countries his entire presidency
folks who never look at foreign coverage
of trump may not know this
but donald trump was not taken seriously
by the newspapers and media outlets
of many countries trump has been ignored
now for years
in many areas climate and others trump
has been one of the least
covered u.s presidents in europe in a
long time because he's been a joke
so for some countries it's not that
they're talking about biden
instead of trump they just weren't
talking about trump
they're going back to talking about an
american president as someone that they
can work with
as someone that they can actually deal
with in a reasonable way
that's a very good thing for the united
states
i've talked before about the mind virus
that is trumpism and i've talked about
the
very real impact that watching fox news
and listening to trump
has on people an economist yougov poll
finds that 86 percent of trump voters
believe joe biden has not legitimately
won the election
86 percent of trump voters fell for the
trump voter fraud scam
which according to reports we got
yesterday
trump doesn't even really believe and is
using just to pay off campaign debt
trump built this up for months saying it
will be rigged
voter fraud is for a voter vote by mail
is fraudulent
etc and it worked in a washington post
poll more than 75 percent of trump
voters believe
trump should not concede so trump
does have the support of his base to
continue not conceding
which is a reminder is merely a
formality concession is not legally
relevant
now even more interesting is that when
asked whether trump
should contest the results of the
election in court about 85 percent of
trump's believe
trump should go to court remember the
latest is trump doesn't even think it
will work
and when asked whether it will work to
change the election results and hand
trump a victory
trumpists are marginally more realistic
but 60 of trump voters
believe what trump is doing will get him
a second term i really need you to
understand that
what we are seeing right now even though
joe biden
is moving forward with appointments and
his transition team
a coronavirus task force the election is
over
foreign leaders are calling joe biden
they're already setting up transition
with joe biden
more than half of trump voters expect
that donald trump will be inaugurated to
a second term on january 20th
this is a mind virus donald trump
succeeded not in winning the election
but in using months of rhetoric about
mail-in ballot fraud
and rigged elections to convince most of
his supporters
that it was rigged and that joe biden
didn't really win
but then we really need to get to the
next part which i mentioned earlier this
week
if you watch fox news at night every
anchor is saying this stuff
it was stolen there was fraud illegal
votes illegal ballots
if you only get your news from fox news
and you look at trump's twitter
why would you think anything else their
go-to news sources
are telling them exactly that and
86 percent of trump voters fell for it
86 percent of trump voters
is more than 60 million people 60
million
people think joe biden didn't really win
these are doctors your kids teachers
accountants waiters truck drivers
you don't get 60 million from you know
unemployed
basement dwelling al qaeda if you
understand what i'm saying
now if you went and you interviewed some
of these 60 million and you asked them
oh okay you think trump actually won by
the way why did you vote for trump
what first term successes are you most
proud of what issues did you care about
their answers will make no sense and
then you'll have a better understanding
of how 86 percent fell for this voter
fraud
uh storyline but i want to go back to
where we started the week on monday
as ignorant as they may be as
unempathetic as they may be
whatever you want to say about these
people whatever you want to believe
about these people
there's 72 million of them okay biden
barely won
when it came to the margins in the key
three states that ultimately won this
for him
we have to do something about those
trumpists i don't yet know what the
answer is and some people wrote to me
saying
you really should be presenting a
solution well i don't have one yet i'm
being upfront i don't know
this is a real problem it's a mind virus
okay
72 million 60 million believe that trump
actually won
i don't yet know the answer but as soon
as i have some ideas i will come to you
we've been wondering what is trump
thinking right now
is he thinking is trump so delusional
that he really thinks he can steal the
election from joe biden
there's a new report from nbc's peter
alexander which is that
trump knows he can't win he's putting on
a show
peter alexander tweeting yesterday
morning quote trump is
very aware there is not a path to
victory but he believes the 72 million
who voted for him deserve a fight
so he's battling as a form of theater
for them a top
white house aide tells me so i
i believe this understand the
multi-level scam that this
is first of all trump has republicans
running all over the country claiming
they have a shot
rudy's in philadelphia eric trump's in
who the hell knows where
uh he's got secretary of state mike
pompeo saying we're going to have a
second trump uh
administration press secretary kelly
mckenney
saying you know every this is all it's
all fraud
is this all an act where everyone knows
it's fake or does trump think it's fake
but all of his sycophants believe it's
real i don't know
next layer of the scam trump is raising
money on this
so even if trump believes this is all
theater in terms of winning
trump is really raising real people's
money
okay for recounts and for legal
challenges
and that's the scam because the fine
print of trump's election fraud
fundraising is that 50 percent of the
money you give
goes not to lawsuits and recounts fifty
percent of the money you give
goes to paying off trump's campaign debt
there are many trump supporters
many on fixed incomes many with low
incomes
who really can't afford to be giving
trump money
and this is not nanny state stuff where
i think someone should protect them
the president is scamming them it's just
the president shouldn't be scamming them
that's it it's not about regulation
if trump knows he can't win and he
realizes that this is theater
he's raising millions of dollars from
people who potentially can't afford to
be donating to trump
who are donating because they think it
might help him win
and trump himself according to peter
alexander
doesn't think this is going to make a
difference he's scamming people
to pay off his campaign debt now i know
you know a fool and their money are soon
parted and all of that stuff
but there are more and more aides coming
forward now and saying there's not even
really the idea of a plan here this is a
straight-up scam
trump aides and advisors and allies have
said
there's no grand strategy here he'll
file a lawsuit he'll send a tweet
whatever there's no strategy
and according to the washington post
quote asked about trump's ultimate plan
one senior administration official
chuckled and said you're giving everyone
too much credit right now
they're just lying to people they know
they're lying to people and they don't
care and it's not just that they're
hurting people
by taking their money they're also
hurting the united states
they're hurting our election process
they're hurting our democracy
and along the way he continues to make
the united states a laughing stock and
he is very clearly i mean it's a
commitment at this point
donald trump is committed to making the
united states a global laughing stock
not i i would argue not just until
january 20th when joe biden becomes
president
but probably well beyond that uh and it
is
all of our you know going back to 2015
2016
all of our worst fears about donald
trump all of our
concerns about how wacky he might be as
president how disastrous
they were understated we've talked
before about this bogus uh
term trump derangement syndrome used
to dismiss criticism of the president
saying oh you people are so hyperbolic
um almost no one was
hyperbolic enough about the presidency
of donald trump that's the reality
it's starting to wrap up and that's a
very good thing
a little bit later today i am going to
talk about
what can joe biden get done if he
doesn't get the senate
will trump really run again in 2024
what's next for the republican party a
lot of very important questions we will
deal with
later i'm glad you're here follow me
on twitter at d pacman and we will be
back
right after this the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that a membership at
joinpacman.com always the best way to
support your favorite or least favorite
or second favorite or third favorite
show
wherever we fall on the ranking sign up
at joinpakman.com coupon code
fresh start let's take some calls
through
our discord uh channel uh discord server
at davidpakman.com discord we're going
to go
first to joseph from costa rica
we've never had a call from costa rica
joseph you're on what is on your mind
today
hi yeah can you hear me i can hear you
okay so i was actually gonna ask if
do you know if there's any president of
actually uh
the right now elected president of the
u.s
of deposing somebody in the supreme
court or
something like that because of the
election of amy coney barrett
i i don't know i don't understand the
question you're saying is there a
president
who's who can depose a supreme court
justice
yeah like actually removing her or
no they you'd have to you'd have to go
through impeachment you'd have to go
through impeachment of a supreme court
justice
oh so that's actually possible do you
see if there's any
possibility of actually joe biden doing
that no
not at all sadly no i think it's much
more likely if joe biden wants to do
something with the court
uh he he would sooner expand the court
add justices
than he would get a um and remember the
impeachment process goes through the
house and senate so ultimately it's not
up to joe biden anyway
okay yeah that's actually pretty bad but
well
at least right now there's a little bit
of hope yes right yeah no i think that
that battle has been lost but there are
other things joe biden could do well
thank you david joseph from costa rica
thank you very much i appreciate that
um we are taking calls through discord
at davidpakman.com
slash discord we are going to go
next to um we're going to
loki from florence now that's florence
where florence could be in a lot of
different places
uh that's actually in florence kentucky
so northern kentucky area
what's going on um not much i've
been watching quite a bit um now just
kind of
i know for probably about the last two
weeks
i've really been watching your live
streams kind of looking at a lot of
different stuff and what is going on
so i just kind of wanted to engage
something by it or at least
double check so just kind of watching
both sides in the way that this is
all advancing and progressing i know
both the republican party and the
democratic party
they have a lot of issues that they're
going to have to go through because
tom's presidency is basically invites a
lot of people
do you see there being any sort of
conflict
military and or otherwise in between the
parties
a military conflict between the
republican and democratic parties you're
saying
yes no what would that even look like i
mean who
who would be controlling the military
who would be directing the military
that's a fair point i do know that there
are several
militias at least that are
kind of practicing i guess i don't oh
okay okay no no but so now that's
you're asking a different question so it
sounds like you're asking is it
conceivable
that i mean i'm guessing you mean
pro-trump militias because that's
that's the those are the militias that
there are it would would like a
pro-trump militia go so crazy
that the military is out in the streets
fighting the pro-trump militia
correct okay that's marginally more
likely i still find i
i still think it's relatively unlikely
but that is marginally more plausible
than than the first scenario which i
think i just misunderstood
yeah i'm kind of doing two or three
things at once but that's my
problem there sorry i'm curious what
what else are you doing because your
phone
connection it's very interesting your
voice it almost sounds like you have a
voice modulator on
oh i've actually got my bluetooth
headphones on i'm
actually kind of cleaning dishes and
listening
uh gotcha okay maybe that it may be that
well listen let's hope it doesn't come
to that okay
definitely yeah all right and is there a
siren going off in the background
uh it could be i actually live right
down the road from a uh police station
at a fire station
it's been going off 24 7 around here wow
all right my friend thank you so much
for the call i appreciate it
okay sounds like sounds like he's gone
let's go next to
tiffany tiffany from unknown location
where are you calling from today
um south carolina south carolina what's
going on there
oh no they won trump
yes and they got them didn't they i
definitely won
um i'm new to all this um i just it's a
lot going on here a lot of conservative
views
um yes they're definitely trying to
get the voter fraud and everything under
play i don't know what are your thoughts
on all of that
well my thoughts are you know they say
let the courts have a say
so far everything that's been brought to
courts courts have found to be
without merit they say networks don't
call
elections that's always the case until
the election is certified but trump was
glad to have networks call it in 2016.
um i mean it's it's all so far
you know they say in pennsylvania we
were too far from the ballots to observe
what was going on
but yet we were close enough to see that
there was signature fraud happening it's
like how could both be true
but i'm curious like in south carolina
are you is this a topic of conversation
like if you go to the corner store or
the grocery store or wherever
is there are people just saying like yep
joe biden he just he had it stolen he
didn't really win is that
happening there well i mean you might
not hear it
for a bit verbatim you know not just
randomly but
they tend to be a bit more republican
yes
yes no that's a that's an understatement
yeah
so yeah but hey i mean everybody
i mean they have their opinion you know
i can't everybody has a right to choose
but i i was just curious like
is he some people say i've heard you
know he's not gonna get reelected so i'm
saying
you just wait wait and see they're going
down and once i
know that there are all of these ideas
of like could
trump do it is there some could trump
you know
use the pentagon to then use the
military to stage a coup
or something like that um i i i just
think the answer is no i i think we
shouldn't even
buy into it joe biden has a transition
team joe biden's a coronavirus task
force
he will be making some uh cabinet um uh
appointments
i just think we we're moving forward you
know that's it
right whether he can seize or not now
tiffany is your family all
uh anti-trump or are there some trumpers
in your family
no well my family is
more for the democratic my husband's
side is a republican so
well we get along really and now
is your husband did your husband vote
trump or is he a biden republican
oh he's no he's for trump wow and and
and it's not a conflict with you for you
guys i mean
no he's he's no i mean hey
great surprisingly yeah
and do you does he say what issues led
him to vote for trump
well i i think it's just a matter of
he's always been very political from
when he was a kid so i mean
he grew up in you know
his mom was public and his dad it kind
of changed the republicans so he's
so it's more like he's culturally
conservative and so
he just voted for trump without really
thinking about the issues right
yeah wow wow and i grew up
more democratic but you know i i tend to
think i'm not
i don't i don't like parties like
labeling myself i don't know if i'm more
i just kind of because i am a christian
obviously but i i
i i'm open to things you know
you said you you said you are a
christian i'm open to different things
i'm not
not negative wise but i'm not i don't
i just don't view i don't like to be
labeled if that makes sense sure yeah
now what was it important to you that
joe biden is
religious um
my viewpoints i i believe in morals and
values but i also
believe in justice and the way things i
just
i always felt there's going to be sort
of a equality there with
all these different rights i do i hear
different viewpoints in this thing this
is going to happen
since he's been elected i haven't seen
the riot the first i don't know if
that's
some coincidence yes
that that is interesting for sure well
we'll see very interesting
well it sounds like uh i mean listen
you're you're making it work with a
trump supporter i think that that's very
interesting
okay tiffany thank you so much for the
call all right
all right take care tiffany married to a
trump supporter
wow let's go next
to um
where are we going let's let's go to
hold on where we have so many people
popping up let's go to
juan from phoenix arizona juan what is
going on
hey what's up david how you doing i love
i'm good i love your show
by the way no problem i i'm just curious
about your opinion on people like
uh john kasich and the lincoln party
grifters
all attacking progressives even though
progressives won
overwhelmingly and progressive policies
won overwhelmingly
on election day absolutely i actually
did a segment earlier this week which
is on the podcast already but we're
saving it for the weekend on youtube and
it's called
these republicans are not your friends
and
you know mitt romney big anti-trump
republican mitt romney
two days after the election he was on tv
saying hey listen my priority
is stopping medicare for all stopping
tax increases
stopping business regulation making sure
no one stops gas and oil
john kasich as you're pointing out
anti-trump republican
defiant and principled goes on tv says
you know the the
joe biden better not let any
progressives influence his policy so
much like we predicted these are not our
friends we use them to the extent that
they're useful
for getting rid of trump we got rid of
trump they're going right back you know
the debt
the deficit all this stuff these are not
our friends full stop
yeah i mean i i agree 100 i just
i just think it's interesting and then
watching aoc try to fight back against
it
i'm just worried that the progressive
party is going to take a big hit if the
entire
establishment decides that it's bad but
progressively you're saying the
progressive wing of the democratic party
yeah yeah and but a majority of the
democratic party don't even like the
progressive wing
of it so i i'm i'm worried about the
progressive
or the progressive wing of the party
yeah no that's you're you're
we talked about that on the wednesday
bonus show and we're going to keep
talking about that but this is this is
an important issue um listen i don't
want to hold you up it sounds like
you're writing a term paper so i'm going
to let you go okay
all right appreciate it david a lot of
feverish
typing going on there we don't want to
there seems like important work is
happening and we don't want to get in
the way of that
let's go to susan now it says susan from
la
is that los angeles is that louisiana
from los angeles susan from los angeles
what's going on
oh um what did you
um i was trying to
connect yesterday but i was wondering
about
the um how the
mcconnell i think it was mcconnell
they're now
supporting trump
yeah i mean mcconnell's playing i mean
listen
yes mcconnell's disgusting and toxic
obviously
mcconnell's kind of playing it a little
bit coy by saying
the president is entitled to all of the
legal recourse
and to demand recounts and everything i
mean i'm wondering
after it's certified i'm wondering what
happens after the certification
if republicans will still keep kind of
playing dumb
my guess is a lot of them after the
certification on december 14th
we'll we'll start just saying joe biden
is the president
but for the time being very few of them
are straight up just saying
yeah biden won and he's the
president-elect and it's pretty vile
it was kind of um
yet it might be good is that
the republicans at least their fight
you know we didn't fight for gore enough
and how we conceded so early yeah
i mean to a humiliating degree
republicans are just continuing
continuing continuing and you can say
that that's virtuous or that
that it's humiliating i guess it depends
on the situation but
obviously i would have liked to have
seen democrats fight more in 2016 with
merrick garland
with amy coney barrett but this is the
situation as it stands today
yeah listen susan what part of la are
you in
i'm right by the airport really yeah
i can hear the plane explain it i love
it it's called westchester
west chester like in new york's
westchester yeah
yeah love it all right susan i hope to
be back in la once it's all
settled down you know that'll be great
all right susan thank you so much we're
going to take a quick break but if
you're holding on to talk to me
please don't hang up don't hang up my
friends because i'm going to be going
back to the phones momentarily
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpackman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
let's go next to abby from idaho abby
from idaho you're on the air
hello yes you're on hi how are you dude
how are you doing david doing well thank
you
um so i actually live in washington
state right now i'm in the navy so i'm
stationed out here but i was i was born
in idaho
oh okay well yeah but we birthplace
residents it's all fine
yes i was just curious what um
because i was talking something to some
of the guys i work with which
most military members are actually kind
of libertarian more than i'd say
republican
um right but i was asking them if they
would
accept court decisions on these voter
fraud cases
right um and i kind of wonder what you
think the trump supporters are going to
do
you know when the courts obviously come
back and say there's not any voter fraud
do you think that they're going to
accept if these state delegates
decide to go for trump they're going to
be you know on that bandwagon of
you're talking about faithless electors
right yeah do you think that they're
going to be on the faithless elector
bandwagon or do you think that they're
going to accept the election
i mean so they're kind of two different
questions the first question is if joe
biden eventually
if if courts say they didn't find any
voter fraud there are going to be some
trumpists who say the courts are biased
and there are some trumpists who might
accept it okay um
if you end up having a situation where
there are faithless electors my guess is
a libertarian would say
hey the the electors are allowed to
go the opposite way of their state if
they believe that it is
important to do so so my guess is that
the libertarian-leaning folks you're
talking about would be fine with it
i don't expect it to happen i i think
that you know we've had faithless
selectors in the past but they've never
reversed the results and with such a
margin for joe biden
you're not going to get 20 or even you
know 36 potentially depending how
georgia goes you're not going to get
that number
yeah and that's that's kind of what we
talked about at work and i also feel
really bad for
some of these guys because they are
republicans but not necessarily trump
supporters and
they have a you know at least like a i
can have thoughtful political discussion
and i feel like these trump supporters
are kind of bringing down their ability
to have like a reasonable discussion
right now you know wait you're saying
you feel bad for anti-trump republicans
yeah i kind of do because they they
they're i do think that having
difference to the political discourse is
important right i'm a progressive and i
wish that everybody you know would be
for medicare for all and
and all the things i want but i realize
it's not a reality you know
yeah that's fair i mean i think you know
let's let's keep everything in context i
feel worse
for the families and victims of
coronavirus than i do for anti-trump
republicans who might be struggling to
have conversations right now but
the point is still well i understand
what you're saying that um the pro-trump
people
they just want to shut everybody down
anti-trump republicans
democrats progressives everybody yeah
and i just want to thank uh you know i
know
all of your listeners at least the
progressive ones are definitely abiding
by social distancing and mask
and you you may not realize this but the
military is taking this stuff very
seriously i am aware of it no i am aware
of it yeah
and for instance like i got in contact
with the guy at work who was coveted
positive for like maybe all of five
minutes and because of that i was stuck
home for two weeks you know
and i did a huge attack tracing at work
which is how everybody should be doing
it really
um but because of that me and my sailors
that work for me we really can't even go
home for the holidays
right so it it really sucks to see these
republicans out there
just you know freaking out about how
much they love the military but they
they refuse to wear a mask
it hurts you know because they're the
reason why i can't go home absolutely my
mom
absolutely you know it's everybody who
wants to you have people who want to
open everything and yet they don't want
to wear masks it's like wait hold on a
second
if everybody wore masks we'd be doing
much better much more could be open
yeah well thanks for talking about this
day all right
abby from idaho currently in washington
state thank you so much
excellent excellent excellent to hear
from you
let me go next to um let's go to
adam from irvine california adam from
irvine what's going on
adam from irvine california can hear
background noise you were on the air
just barely
marginally are you running a buzz saw in
the background
i want to know what you think about
trump's uh
military advisor
are you using an electric shaver right
now
it's my computer was the question about
trump firing military advisors
yes oh okay listen i'm gonna take it off
air because it's
it's that's wild um listen uh
so trump firing military advisers
there's kind of two questions
one if he's out in nine weeks why is he
firing anybody what difference does it
make that so that's that's sort of like
one question
the other side of it is is this part of
a planned military coup
um i think this is just trump's a
petulant child and he's firing people
who he's been at odds with and he would
have fired the months ago were it not
for
somebody saying hey you know what um you
might want to wait until after the
election i
i perfectly to be perfectly honest i
think it's that simple
i don't think we should read much more
into it and you know there's people
acting like uh
trump's a criminal genius here staging
some coup by replacing mark esper i
i just don't see it i really don't let
me go next to
connie from kenosha wisconsin
hello hi how are you i'm great how are
you
i'm doing well feliz dia de los
veteranos
gracias so
i am addicted to watching your show
and amongst everything else um
surrounding
this mess that we're in um but
i have to wonder as far as
the transition that
has pretty much happened with every
other
um president-elect in the past
um why
is there no path around
um certain certain
blocks that they're encountering as far
as the head of
gsa um you know
making certain information available to
joe biden
i i'm really having a hard time
understanding
why it's just being
why this is being allowed so all of
these things are
different so so the important thing is
to separate out a lot of these different
things so
trump hasn't conceded that's a formality
it doesn't relate to anything else it
doesn't change that he won't be
president anymore
on january 20th at noon then you've got
the gsa
question trump has not signed off and
authorized
gsa to sort of start involving
the biden elect camp in the transition
and um that is an inconvenience but as
joe biden said earlier this week it
doesn't materially change anything now
joe biden is not currently the president
so he really can't do anything about
that
but the important thing to understand is
it won't change the fact that he will be
sworn in on january 20th
so it's important to sort of divide
these things up
into which ones are just sore loserish
and which ones really have an impact
the one that for me is the most
concerning is joe biden should be
receiving the presidential daily
briefing already
and he's not as of right now that trump
doesn't even read it
well sure you're right so at this but
but so to your point
we have a situation right now where
trump is miserable
and hiding out at the white house and
ignoring the pdb
biden's not getting it if i were
a terrorist enclave
in some other country i would be aware
that the u.s is very vulnerable right
now because they've got no one reading
the pdb and you're going to get a
president coming in on january 20th
who will not have been receiving it
unless something changes so i think it
actually puts our puts national security
at risk
well and i think that it points out and
brings to light
that donald trump truly
really does not have the country's best
interest at heart
never did and he absolutely does not
you're completely correct about that
right well kenosha's doing fine
everything's okay here
thank you still boarded up but yeah i'm
glad to hear that connie thank you for
calling in today
thank you very much love your show thank
you there's connie from
kenosha what a phone call um
i would even say maybe perfect phone
call i don't know
let's see um
i guess there there might be a trumpist
from the bronx holding is am i
understanding that correctly are you a
pro-trump
person from the bronx
oh uh absolutely not that's just that's
just the name
ghost you're not a trump supporter
oh not at all oh okay what's going on
well i just i'm you know being a
democrat it's kind of hard to date
somebody who's
baddest you know or racist and and a
[ __ ]
or right republican so i was wondering
how do you recommend with deal
we deal with with that situation when
you know your
your partner's families are trumpers and
are so far right well now let me ask you
your your partner's family or your
partner as well
no no mike my girlfriend is completely
democrat
you know she's 100 percent of my her dad
used to be a cop he actually got fired
for
you know using racist tactics and i am a
and so it's kind of difficult for me to
interact with him
yeah so i'm wondering what kind of way
is it you know what can i approach you
to take
so i'm understanding your girlfriend is
not latino
no she is she's 100 white yeah
that's tough i mean listen uh if if it
were the actual partner
i don't think i could do it you know
it's like if there's a difference over
the degree to which the gender pay gap
exists it's like listen we can bridge
that gap that's no problem
if there's a difference over you know
some nominal religious belief i think
that's fine i i think it would be very
difficult to actually date a full-on
trumpist now the family
the family i think is manageable if you
you know think if you're careful and
it's really about how important it is
for you to maintain a relationship with
her family i mean there's people in my
girlfriend's family who are very
conservative
evangelical you know we don't really see
them um just because of distance
but um it's just you know you you
basically are just agreeing not to talk
about politics is is it now where it
becomes difficult
is sometimes there will be people
trumpists who
even though everybody knows it would be
better not to talk about politics
they because it pervades their world
view they can't help
saying something racist or whatever
and you feel like i can't say nothing
but at the same time if i respond i'm
starting a fight
those situations are really difficult i
don't know how to manage them
right don't agree with you you know
thanksgiving coming up
yeah going to be difficult to be there
it's going to be a mess it's going to be
a mess now i'm
i wonder at multi at families that are
split politically
by thanksgiving are you going to have
the trump people
insisting that joe biden is an
illegitimate president because that's
going to make for some awkward past the
sweet potatoes moments you know
you will you're right well thank you so
much for your advice dude i really
appreciate your show i'm enjoying it
more than ever now
thank you so much i i really appreciate
you calling in great to uh
great pho wow what what phone calls
today um
let's go next to talia
from is it raleigh or rally north
carolina i always forget how it's
pronounced
yes hi hi how are you great it's so
great to be talking to you david
likewise um so i have an interesting
idea that i'd like to run
past you and see what you think sure
so recently you've seen like democrats
like joe manchin who basically act like
republicans and get in the way
of whenever democrats can maybe do
something so i'm thinking
we should run progressives in the
republican party i think our
ideas would be great and it would cancel
out people like joe manchin
and also i think that it's important to
not just play offense but also play
defense
and i mean the republicans do it they
definitely have a republican in the
democratic party and joe manchin
and yeah i was wondering what you think
of that i'd have to think about that so
the idea is
instead of primarying joe manchin with a
progressive
in the democratic primary you run
progressives in the republican primaries
everywhere um i don't think we should
just take over the democratic party we
should probably take over the entire
government
because yeah but i just don't see
republican primaries going to
progressives
i think i think it could i think um
republicans
would take too many progressive ideas
like we see in
like florida where they're voting for
minimum wage and um these drug
um drugs running you know the the war on
drugs if we run on
issues like that i think we would get a
lot of crossover
if they wouldn't yes i just i just don't
i can't think of any place where a
progressive
would win a republican primary but let
me think about it a little more okay
talia
yeah all right talia from north carolina
very much appreciate the call
that will do it for calls today but fear
not
we will take calls again in the future
the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going
is through patreon where you can pledge
as little as one dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show
great perks and benefits as well read
about them
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right let's get to some of your
questions for the week one that i got a
bunch of times including during live
calls on um
uh what day was that live calls on
tuesday
uh was is donald trump really going to
run again in 2024 there have already
been rumors swirling that donald trump
supposedly is telling advisers he's
going to run in 2024.
first of all we should sort of be
skeptical of that because if donald
trump
still exists in the state of denial in
which he seems to be living
i don't know that he still is really
believing that
it's over only if you believe it's over
would you
start thinking about 2024 so maybe he's
been saying it
maybe he hasn't i think the the there's
a couple different ways to approach this
first of all i kind of doubt it he will
be 78 almost 79 at inauguration that
would make him even older than joe biden
is now
joe biden already the oldest president
to be inaugurated into
um the the white house so i think
in the you know trump has what seems to
be sort of adult adhd
i think that over four years trump's
going to um a lot's going to happen to
trump and who knows what he will be
doing from four years from now i don't
find it particularly likely
secondly we really can't control that
right now there's nothing we can do
about that right now and so
i i when the when callers ask me this
um my i will speculate today but i am
going to go back to what i was saying
you know in 2017 when people ask me
about 2020 i would say we have a midterm
here that we have to deal with
so i think that we should not really
worry about it at this point in time and
take the approach of
we'll deal with that when the time comes
now in terms of
what the nominee and even the republican
primary would look like in 2024 with or
without trump
we need to see what happens to the
republican party in the next two and
four years
and we're going to talk about that next
but there are lots of names that
and remember in 2012 if you had asked
who's a likely republican candidate
you weren't going to hear donald trump
from too many people so i say this
knowing that we're terrible at figuring
this stuff out
but in looking at what are possibilities
could a child of trump run in 2024
don jr or ivanka i think it's less
likely with trump losing but it's
possible
marco rubio all of a sudden seems to be
acting as if he's already running for
2024 republican nominee
tucker carlson is being mentioned by a
lot of people that one's actually scary
to me because i think in today's
environment tucker carlson could
actually win a republican primary which
is really scary
in four years i don't know um right-wing
extremist lunatic
tom cotton's name is being mentioned
there's always the possibility of a
former vice president running which
would
maybe put mike pence in there although
he's so uncharismatic that it is hard to
imagine but it's within the realm of
possibility
ted cruz is a name that continues to be
thrown around and sean hannity
calls him one of the greatest legal
minds or something like that so
certainly it's somebody who would get a
boost
if the republican party decides to go
the direction of a woman
nikki haley comes to mind years ago i
would have said what about condoleezza
rice as maybe the first
republican presidential nominee i think
condi rice
with her disagreement and distance with
trumpism
is is a less likely option for 2024 but
maybe it could be nikki haley
would jeb bush try to sweep back in and
say hey guys let's go back to sanity
my brother was saying this is what he
would say and i will be sane and you
know we can go back to just like boring
evangelical type republicans
these are all possibilities it really is
impossible to know at this point in time
i don't believe it's worth putting a lot
of time into we have
uh objectives that are happening right
now the objective
in the immediate is we have just under
two months until there are two
senate runoff elections in georgia that
will determine who controls the senate
that is where 98 percent of our efforts
need to be the other two percent just on
keeping an eye on trump and making sure
he doesn't do anything too crazy in
these
remaining weeks after that point it will
be
a year of what is joe biden's first year
pushing for him to get things done that
are possible
with a democratic senate if he has it
without a democratic senate if if he
doesn't have it and we'll talk about
what those things are momentarily
we will then go right into the 2022
election and
uh that is going to start before you
know it we're probably you know 10
months from the from the early stages
of 2022 election and
um that if democrats don't take control
of the senate this time
which remains to be seen taking control
of the senate in 2022 will be a
massive priority and in fact if
democrats don't get the senate this time
getting the senate in 2022 is what
all of joe biden's first term successes
the major successes legislative
successes
could ride on so that will be massively
important and then when the time comes
we will get to talking about 2024
but i would not spend more time than is
worth spending on it at this point in
time
and this gets us right into question
number two today
with trump losing what is next for the
republican party this is a question i've
received
dozens of times over the last week
the tougher question for me about the
gop
is what happens in the next two weeks
and two months
do they back trump do they all start
saying it's time to resign
does trump try to do something crazy
during the lame duck and if so do
republicans get in the way
or do they just look the other way or do
they help him do it
the longer question about republicans
seems pretty unambiguous to me you've
already seen clips
i've played them for you this week from
willard mitt romney
and john kasich they're immediately
going back to standard republican
talking points
we have to block medicare for all we
have to
deal with the deficit which they didn't
talk about at all under trump
republicans are going right back to just
being
republicans once donald trump is gone
it also has to be considered and i dealt
with this earlier in the week
pope spent 10 minutes 15 minutes talking
about it democrats failed to get
a large repudiation of donald trump
donald trump
lost by thin margins in three to four
states
trump almost got re-elected at the
electoral level
and although joe biden's popular vote
margin is great
donald trump got millions more votes
than he got in 2016.
71 million votes for donald trump
when you get 71 million votes for your
candidate
even if you lose especially if you think
it was stolen you're not necessarily
going to say we need to change
everything we're doing
there may be changes at the state level
uh georgia
looking at georgia looking at how close
texas was you may see republican
strategy change
within some states in really particular
ways but republicans are going to
continue to do well and anyone who says
otherwise maybe is not aware of the
history of how quickly
the two political parties bounce back
from losses
and even from big losses this is not a
big loss
in the sense that republicans are
gaining in the house
they may even remain retain control of
the senate and
and trump got 71 million votes so
with republicans being better at the
local level with republicans having
better ground game
generally but not always i am not
expecting major changes in the
republican party i'm expecting the
republican party to revert
essentially back to what it was up until
donald trump became the nominee
i would expect the republican party uh
to continue
using their wedge issues including those
religiously tied issues
like abortion less so gay marriage but
now it's religious freedom
to raise money although it may become a
little bit more difficult over time
but i'm not expecting major changes
other than a lot of republicans who were
with trump for the last four
years who will pretend they never were
and even start to pretend trump
trump we don't we don't even remember
trump really that is what i am expecting
from them so i don't expect
major changes to the republican party i
think the next two weeks and two months
will be key
in terms of who's with trump and who is
not with trump
and the question of the senate gets us
directly into question number three
today
what can joe biden get done without the
senate
uh as i've mentioned a dozen times this
week
control of the senate is not yet
determined there are two
runoff senate races in georgia which
will happen on january 5th we'll be
covering them
very extensively if democrats get both
it will be 50 50 making kamala harris as
vice president
the tie-breaking vote democrats could
effectively control the senate
but the question is without the senate
what can get done
let's go through it first of all there's
a long list of executive orders a lot of
the disasters donald trump got us into
with executive orders
he can get us out of anything trump did
unilaterally
joe biden can undo unilaterally and
we've already talked about getting back
into paris climate getting
back into the who getting rid of the
military trans ban
reinstating the dreamer program uh doing
a lot with covid and he's already
launched a task force there's tons of
agency stuff you know trump has
reoriented the epa
to be weak joe biden could reorient the
epa
to be stronger to protect the
environment um
nasa was directed to stop studying
climate joe biden can get nasa to be
studying climate again
uh so there is quite a bit that joe
biden can do
foreign policy biden can do a lot of a
lot of foreign policy
things that aren't budgetary and thus
need to go through the house and senate
um but there's a lot of foreign policy
fixing relationships
fixing a bunch of the trade stuff with
china if china is willing
maybe getting us back into the iran
nuclear deal a lot of that can be done
without controlling the senate
the stuff that will be difficult is you
know infrastructure including green
infrastructure you need the house and
senate uh
tax reform real health care
reform you're going to need the house
and senate for that
unless you make deals with the devil
essentially unless you make compromises
that
i can't imagine joe biden would want to
do and that would be sort of my one area
of
of caution which is it's great for joe
biden to talk about i will be the
president whether you voted for me or
not
i will be the president of the united
states not just of blue states
rather than red states it's great that
joe biden is saying that it's great that
joe biden
is you know a guy who has been able to
work across the aisle
these people are disgusting though these
republicans and the idea that you're
going to get
your agenda done with their help is
ridiculous
you you could maybe get pyrrhic
victories the idea of a pyrrhic victory
is
you win but you do so much
self-inflicted damage in winning that
you end up wondering is that really a
win anymore
and the way that would work out as a
pyrrhic victory would be
you get something done on paper but the
compromises you make
damage the country in such a way that it
ends up being awash for example
i think that's the risk of joe biden i
think there would be a naivete if joe
biden really thinks he's going to work
with these clowns
my hope is and i don't pretend to know
we'll see and if it doesn't go this way
we'll criticize biden
my hope is that biden is using language
of uniting
the american people but he is not
naively thinking
he's going to get a lot of this big
stuff done by working with republicans
because they're just not going to work
with him in any way that would
approximate what we would call
a leftward move it remains to be seen
i'm not putting the cart before the
horse i will criticize it
if it happens but i am going to hope and
lobby
that joe biden accurately understands
that these are not people
that you can negotiate with uh or or
that you can bargain with
because you will just damage yourself
that's my sense right now
i'd love to hear your thoughts we have a
great bonus show today
you can get instant access by using the
coupon code fresh start when you sign up
at joinpakman.com
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist the app that
lets you
read or listen to an entire non-fiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video